[موسيقى]
الى الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
اسرائيل
وذخائر خاصه وطائرات تزويد الوقود
سوريا تطالب دمشق بالدفع مقدما مقابل
النفط وبالاسعار العالميه
من الدبابات الى الاسلحه الثقيله الغرب
يحشد في اوكرانيا ويختبر نفس بوت عسكريا
طائره نيبال المنكوبه مصرع جميع الركاب من
بينهم 15 اجنبيه وسبب الكارثه قيد التحقيق
قيمه العمله المشفره تقترب من تريليون
دولار وحجم التداولات يرتفع 80 بالمئه
خلال اخر 24 ساعه
[موسيقى]
وساعه مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
قال مصدر العسكري اسرائيلي ان خطه بلاده
مستقلا على منشات ايران النوويه ليست
جاهزه بعد ولكن قد يتغير الوضع في حال
استقبل الجيش اوامره من المستوى السياسي
لذا اضاف المسؤول العسكري ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيواصل التجهيز لضربه عسكريه
الايران عبر شراء مقاتلات وذخائر خاصه ثم
ذكر ذكر باهميه الغارات الاسرائيليه على
سوريا ودورها في تعطيل موضوع ايران
العسكري حسبته اما في اوكرانيا فحذر
المصدر العسكري ان اسرائيل ترصد اداء
ايران بتفعيل المسيرات في اوكرانيا ولديها
حلول لمواجهه هذه القدرات وفي جزء اخر من
هذه التصريحات المسربه علق المسؤول
والاستخباراتيه على الوضع في الضفه
الغربيه محذرا من تصعيد محتمل
[موسيقى]
وضعت ايران القيود توريد على النفط الرخيص
الى سوريا الامر الذي تسبب في ازمه حيث
قامت طهران بمضاعفه السعر الذي تدفعه دمشق
مقابل النفط الخام الايراني مما ادى الى
نقص الوقود في سوريا تزامنا مع انهيار
الاقتصابها وحسب وسائل الاعلام سوريا تسبب
النقص في طوابير انتظار امام محطات الوقود
السوريه ايران رفعت السعر من 30 الى اكثر
من 70 دولار للبرميل حسب الاستجرام
وفي ايران ايضا تشتحو موجه واسعه من البرد
والعواصف الثلجيه العديده من المناطق وسط
البلاد
وهذا في ظل ازمه الطاقه التي تشهدها ايران
ففي محافظه اراك و خراسان وحدها بات
90,000 ساكن دون غاز بحسب مصادر محليه
ويقول المسؤولون ان درجات الحراره وصلت
الى مستويات غير مسبوقه ما رفع الطلبه على
الوقود لمستويات القياسيه وادت شده البرد
الى توقف المدارس وانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي واغلاقه بعض محطه الوقود في
جميع انحاء البلاد وفي الوقت الذي تتفاقم
فيه الازمه يوما بعد يوم اعلن وزير خارجيه
ايران حسين امير عبد الله هيام استعداد
بلاده لارسال الوقود الى لبنان
نذهب الى بيروت نتابع مع علي الامين رئيس
تحرير موقع جنوبيه استاذ علي اهلا بك معنا
لماذا هذا القرار الايراني مع حلفتها
سوريا
لتغيير الاسعار وطلب الدفع سلفا
لمقابل النفطه الخام الايراني وبالاسعار
العالميه ليس بسعر رخيص كما كان في السابق
لا تنسى تحياتي لكم
هذا الامر
[موسيقى]
على الاقل
سوريا
خارجيه سوري على الاقل ولم يكن معترض على
السياقه
بانه هذه الزياره ايضا في السياق التطورات
المهمه
القرار الايراني ربما الى الى توازنات
سياسيه ليس لازمه اقتصاديه تعاني منها
ايران
حرام
الضغط اكثر من ما هو تعبير عن اجمل
الاقتصاديه الماليه
بهدف ماذا الضغط على النظام السوري لاي
هدف
عدم الانحراف
الدول
تركيا
الى ازعاج ايران من الحركه التركيه
الاخيره في ما يتصل في التواصل
ومعروف
على النظافه
اكثر مستقبلات على موقع ايران في سوريا
استاذ علي ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود اليك
بعد قليل مشاهدينا يوصلوا النظام الايراني
انتاج السياسه الاعدام في حق العديد من
الشخصيات البارزه وهذه المره مع المواطن
البريطانيه الايرانيه علي رضا اكبر حد اا
مستشاري شمخاني سابقا بتهمه التجسس ونقل
اسرار الدوله الى بريطانيا
بعد اعدام علي رضا اكباري المثير للجدل
وردود الفعل الغربيه المهدده تظهر تطورات
الاحداث في ايران ان عمليه الاعدام ما هي
الا مقدمه لصنع متوقع في هيكل النظام
الايراني
وليس ادل على ذلك ما سرب من حديث اجبري مع
القاضي المكلف بمحاكماته
فواحده من التهم التي اعدم اكبر بسببها هي
حصوله على معلومات سريه عن الدوله من امين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي شامخاني
مقابل زجاجه عطر وقميص
وهنا كان سؤال اكبر البدايه للقاضي اذا
كان شمخاني سرب هذه المعلومات اليه فلماذا
لا يحاكم معي
لكن رد القاضي كان مفاجئا اذ قال للشاكي
ليس لدي القوه لاستدعاء شمساني لكنني
سادمرك انت
طبعا كل هذا بالاضافه لما تعرض له اكبر من
تعذيب لفتره طويله ان فزعت خلالها
اعترافاته قصرا
السؤال الذي يدور الان بين دوائر
المتابعين هل كان اكبري هو الهدف ام شم
خان نفسه
ايران انترناشونال قالت وفقا للوثائق حصلت
عليها من داخل الحرس الثوري ان الاطاحه
بشمخاني هي الهدف الاكبر مما حدث لاكبر
وحتى الشبكات التابعه للحرس الثوري على
تليغرام تناولت معلومات عن اقاله الرجل
لكن المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي نفى ذلك تماما بل ان الحديث امتد
الى خليفته القادمه
على وزير الداخليه احمد وحيد باعتباره
صاحب اكبر الفرص
ويرى معارضون ان النظام قد يكونوا في
مرحله محاسبه من يعتقد انهم خذلوه خلال
موجه الاحتجاجات الاخيره
الى التدخل لاخماد الاحتجاجات
ووعد بالسعي لتقديم مزيد من الحريه وتحقيق
بعض مطالب المحتاجين هذا النهج لم يرق
لصقور النظام الذين راوا على الدوام ان
القبضه الحديديه هي الحل لعلاج كل
المشكلات
واعود مره اخرى اليك استاذ علي الامين في
بيروت ونعود لنقاش موضوع القيود التي
وضعتها ايران على بيع النفط الخام
لسوريا
وعودتها عن هذا القرار انت وضعته في اطار
انه ربما الضغط السياسي على دمشق حتى لا
تذهب بعيدا في التفاهمات مع روسيا وتركيا
ايضا همم
ما ردت الفعل المتوقعه برايك من قبل
النظام السوري هنا على هذه الخطوه
يعني اولا يجب ان ندرك اولا انه يعني هذا
ايران تعريفه وكل الاطراف انه النظام
السوري هو الحلقه الاضعف في كل المعادله
الاقليميه الجاريه او الديوانيه ايضا
الجاريه في سوريا يعني بين التاثير الروسي
على رغم تراجع يعني ميسي
بسبب الاوكرانيه
التواصل مع النظام السوري
لكن يبقى على الاقل في العنوان الشرعيه ان
هذا النظام هو الذي يطفي شرعيه على اي
تفاهمات او اتفاقات تحصل هو التساؤل الذي
يطرح اليوم هو على الاقل انه لماذا ايران
ليس ضمن هذه التفاهمات ايران حاولت في
فتره سابقه في ان تحدث نوع من التقارب من
تركيا والنظام السوري في فتره ولكن ايران
تريد ان تلعب بالدوري المؤثر في هذه
المعادله ربما المسارات التي يمكن ان تذهب
فيها ولا اقول ان الامور ذاهبه باتجاه
ربما معاكس لايران لكن ايران بطبيعه
وجودها ونفودها تبقى قلقه في سوريا الى حد
كبير بمعنى انها محتاجه دائما الى هذه
الشرعيه وهذا الغطاء بالتالي النظام
السوري بتقدير الى حد كبير لا يمكن ان
يستخدم هذه الورقه في مواجهه الروس
والاتراك اكثر من ربما يعني يمكن ان يرد
عليها سلبا وليس لديه القدره برايه لانه
حدث في مواقع النظام تبقى الاراده
الايرانيه هي الاراده
ميدانيا وعلى الارض لحد كبير ولا يمكن ان
نتحدث عن امكانيه سوريه فعلا لنظام ان
يكون مستقلا تماما عن الاراده الايرانيه
وهذا امر تعرفونه تراكب مع السنوات الى حد
كبير شكرا جزيلا لك على الامين رئيس تحرير
موقع جنوبيه وانت معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا عوده الى خبرنا الاول في اخبار
الساعه المتعلق بالتسريبات الاسرائيليه عن
مصدر العسكري اسرائيلي بشان خطه بلاده
لتجهيز
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه اذا
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من القدس استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه في الجامعه
العبريه في القدس دكتور المصري دكتور ماير
اهلا بك في ايطار يمكن وضع الحديث مره
اخرى لتجهيز استهداف المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه من قبل اسرائيل خاصه انه ليست
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها الحديث عنها
شكرا على الصداقه يا استاذ صهيب تحياتي لك
ولجميع المشاهدين لا شك في انه اسرائيل
مستمر في
وعظمه على تحضير العمل العسكري كبير في
العمق الايراني هي الخطباء الشهيره التي
لا تلوح بها اسرائيل وانما بات تلوح بها
الولايات المتحده اليوم اقنعت اسرائيل
المجتمع الدولي بشرعيه بمشروعيه العمل
التي الذي قد تقوم به اسرائيل ولكن من
المنظور الاسرائيلي ليس هناك تلويح او ردع
وانما هناك تحضير تجهيز هناك خمسه مليارات
شكل اي مليار ونصف مليار دولار صرفوا حتى
هذه اللحظه في شراء اسلحه ومعدات وذخيره
من الولايات المتحده همم الذين يتحدثون عن
ضوء اخضر او عدم توافر من قبل واشنطنطينيه
تتعلق بعمل عسكري يعني الاداره الامريكيه
مادام قابلت بتزويد همم اسرائيل بهذه
الاسلحه فهي اعطت بالفعل الضوء الاخضر
لضرب المشاهدات النوويه الايرانيه اذا لزم
الامر
لا شك في هذا اولا ااا
بيع هذه الاسلحه رغم ان هناك صفقه الاربع
مروحيات التي سوف تستلمها اسرائيل في
نهايه العام الجاري وسيتحاول ان تعجل
باجراء الصفقه ولكن كل هذه الاسلحه
والمعادلات لا تفيد اسرائيل الا في عمل
عسكري في العمق الايراني فقط غير مفيده
لاسرائيل في اي عمل اخر وبالتالي لا شك ان
هناك حد ادنى من التوتر الامريكي متى يمكن
ان تستخدم هذه الخطه او تفاعل هذه الخطه
المصدر العسكري الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن همم
اذا كان هناك امر سياسي مع انه الخطه قال
ليست جاهزه بعد همم ما المقصود هنا هل همم
يعني متى يمكن ان تفعل هذه الخطه وتصبح
جاهزه همم
يصدر هذا الامر السياسي
استاذ صهيب يجب علينا ان ياخذ معنا اعتبار
اعمل هام الغايه في اي عمل عسكري قد تكون
تقوم به اسرائيل وهو عامل المفاجاه
المفاجاه اسرائيل
سوف تقوم نحن
نوح استعداد ولكن ربما بعد اشهر وتقوم
بالعمل ت
ذكر او وكذلك النظام الايراني ان حصل على
القنبله الذريه سوف يكون في يوم في صباح
ما يعلن هذا على الملا كما اعلنت الهند او
باكستان او الاتحاد السوفيتي في السابق او
الصين كل هذه الدول
يعني اسرائيل تريد فعلا على وشك ان تقوم
بهذه الضربه ام لا لانه في كل مره كان يتم
الحديث عن هذا ليست المره الاولى
بالتاكيد هناك عنصر منوره في الموضوع
قد تكون لا اعرف تفاصيل الامور ولكن انا
استطيع ما استطيع ان اقول ان اقوله هو انه
اسرائيل عازمه نعم اسرائيل عازمه على
القيام بعمل عسكري كبير في الداخل
الايراني بالتنسيق هو اقليميه وبوجود اكثر
من الضوء اخضر من قبل الولايات المتحده
انخراط امريكي لانه السلاح امريكي
والولايات المتحده تعاهدت وبشكل واضح
ومكت نعم تدافع عن اسرائيل تدافع عن
اسرائيل في حين تعرضت لهجمه ايرانيه
انتقاميه في سياق عمل عسكري تبادر به
اسرائيل
شكرا جزيلا لك ماير مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه
مع وضع رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد
شروط لاعاده تطبيع العلاقات مع انقره
ابرزها انهاء لوجود التركيه على الاراضي
السوريه عادت مسالته تعذيب بنود اتفاقيه
بين انقره ودمشق للواجهه مجددا وهو مطلب
تركي بالطبع الذي يدعو الى توسيع
الاتفاقيه لتشمل حقا الدخول مسافه 30 كم
بدلا من خمسه وفقا لنسخه من 98
[موسيقى]
الحلفاء الغربيون لاوكرانيا يواصلون
اغداقها بالاسلحه والحلف الاطلسي يؤكد
ارسال الشحنات جديده من الاسلحه الثقيله
التاكيد جاء على لسان الامين العام لحلف
شمال الاطلسي ستورمبرج الذي قال ان
التعاهدات الاخيره تضمنت تسليم اسلحه
المهمه لاوكرانيا متوقعا المزيد في
المستقبل القريب
تعاهدات النايته هذه تاتي بعد ايام قليله
من تعهد فرنسا والمانيا والولايات المتحده
بتزويد اوكرانيا باليات مدرعه لنقل المشاه
او للاستطلاع منها 40 مدرعه المانيا من
طراز ماردر وخمسين مدرعه امريكيه من
طرازلي وعدد من مدرعات اي ام اكس 10
الفرنسيه كما تعهدت المملكه المتحده السبت
بارسال اربعه 10 دبابه ثقيله من طراز
تشالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا في الاسابيع
ميدانيا اعلنت سلطاتك روسيا استانست
الهجمات الصاروخيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وغيرها من المناطق فكانت موسكو وكثافه
قصفها ما ادى الى اصدار السلطات
الاوكرانيه تحذيرا من غاره جويه في جميع
انحاء البلاد وجاء القصف الروسي بعد يوم
من اعلان موسكو السيطره الكامله على مدينه
سوليدار وهو ما نفته اوكرانيا التي اكدت
ان معارك طاحنه لا تزال تدور في هذه
البلده الصغير
تشالنجر اثنان العمود الفقري لقوه
الدبابات في الجيش البريطاني وهي وحيده من
اربع دبابات قتاليه الرئيسيه طورتها دول
حلف الناتور لخوض الحروب فهل ستقدر على
مواجهه الدبابه تي 90 الروسيه احدى افضل
دبابات العالم من حيث الحمايه والتدريع في
ساحه المعركه باكرانيا طول دبابه تشالنجر
اثنان يتجاوز احد عشر مترا ووزنها اثنين
و60 طنا ونصف دبابه ثقيله الحركه سرعتها
تصل الى 59 كم في الساعه ويصل مداها الى
400 و50 كلم اما تي 90 فطوله هيكلها اقل
من سبعه امتار ووزنها اخف بكثير ويصل الى
نحو 48
بالذخائر
قدره عاليه على المناوره مع سرعه القصوى
تصل الى 70 كم في الساعه بينما يصل مداها
الى 500 كلم تشالنجر اثنان دبابه مصممه
لمهاجمه الدبابات الاخرى وتدميرها
على دروع ثقيله ومدفعين الرئيسي من عيار
120 م ب 52 قذيفه بالاضافه لمدفعين اخرين
بمقدار اربعه الاف طلقه في ما المدفع
الرئيسي للذبابه الروسيه فهو من عيار 225
ملم اجمالي طلقات مع مدفعين اخرين
2340 طلقه ومجهزا بصواريخ موجهه مداها
خمسه كيلومترات تتميز تي 90 بنظام اليل
للتحكم في اطلاق النار الدبابات
باستطاعتها البحث عن الاهداف وتعقبها في
وضع الثبات او الحركه ليلا او نهارا ايا
كانت الظروف الجويه اما تشالنجر فهي مصممه
لعبور التضاريس المفتوحه وتمثلها بذلك
الدبابه الروسيه ذات القدره العاليه على
اجتياز الموانع الطبيعيه
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايجور
كوناشينيكوف اكد ان القوه الروسيه حققت
تقدما في مناطق الشماليه باخ مد خلال
القتال يوم امس حيث تمكنت من قتل 80 جندي
الاوكرانيا وتدمير دباباتين و 30 عربات
قتاليه مدرعه وثلاث سيارات في يوم واحد
في اتجاه الدونتس حققت مفارز الهجوم
بالتعاون مع وحدات من القوات المحموله جوا
ودعم من طيران الجيش والقوات الصواريخ
والمدفعيه للمنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه حققت
نجاحا في اتجاه الضواحي الشماليه في باخوط
خلال القتال تم القضاء على اكثر من 80
جنديا اوكرانيا ودبابتين وثلاثين مركبات
قتاليه مدرعه وثلاث سيارات في يوم واحد
بلاده جاهزه للرد على اي اعمال
الاستفزازيه من جانب اوكرانيا وزير
الخارجيه في مجلس الامن في بيلاروسيا فاضل
مورابيكو اتهم اوكرانيا بانتهاك الامني
على الحدود والقيم باستفزازات على حد كشف
ان المناورات الجويه بين بيلاروسيا وروسيا
المقرر اجرائها الاسبوع المقبل ذاته طبيعه
دفاعيه او سيتم تنفيذه طلعات الاستطلاع
والتصدي من الهجمات واكد مجلس الامن
البيلاروسيا ان التدريبات الفاعيه
الاقليميه من المخطط اجرائها في الربع
الاول من العام الجرس
نتابع مباشره من كياب مع مراسلنا حذيفه
عادل حذيفه اسالك بدايه عن اخر واهم
التطورات الميدانيه
مساء الخير يا صهيب في الحقيقه اولا ابدا
بالسوليدار التي تم ت- يعني الحديث عنها
بكثافه اا اليوم في موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وهنالك كثير من الاجهادات وكثير
من الاخبار المتضاربه لذلك تحدثت قبل قليل
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان مولر
وقالت ان القتال في سوليدار ما زال يدور
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه مازلنا
نقاتل من اجل سوليدار وعلى الجميع ان لا
يلتفت للدعايه الروسيه وكذلك طلبت الناس
بعدم تداول همم يعني المعلومات التي تنشر
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وان هذا
الامر يضر
يعني بالمعارك ويدور ما يحدث على ارض
الواقع هذا من ذلك طبعا ايضا ضخمه اليوم
تعرضت لي عدد من الهجمات قالت وزاره
الدفاع عنها استطاعه ضد الهجمات في اتجاه
باخوه كذلك اليوم في كرمنا وفي نقاس كان
هنالك من قبل القوات الروسيه كما قالت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها ان القوات
الروسيه هناك تحاول من تحسين وضعها
الاستراتي لذلك القوات وصيه تحاول من على
ذلك وكذلك في اتجاه لمن كان هنالك هجمه
جديده ايضا وزاره الدفاع قالت انها صدت
الهجوم في اتجاه لمن هذا بالاضافه الى
ضربات الصاروخيه في اف دي اف كا وكذلك في
اليكسان نعم طيب حديث الحلفاء الغربيين
لكيف بالاستمرار في دعمها بالسلاح همم هل
هناك اي تعليق صدر عن المسؤولينا الاوكران
وهل هناك اي تفاصيل اخرى حول الدعم
المنتظر
في الحقيقه يعني اخر تصريح كان من برج قبل
حوالي ساعتين الذي قال ان الدعم همم
للجيش الاوكراني مستمر وسوف نقوم همم
الدفع بالاسلحه الثقيله الى الجيش
الاوكراني طبعا ايضا
مرحبا بالقرارات المتخذه من بعض الشركاء
في همم
الاسلحه الثقيله والمتقدمه نحن نتحدث عن
الدبابات الفرنسيه ام اكس 10 التي همم
يعني صرح بذلك الرئيس الفرنسي من وين
ماكرون في محادثه هاتفيه مع الرئيس الاسكي
وكذلك تشالنجر ولكن اللافت ايضا ان هنالك
الان يدور حديث في برلين حول
ايضا الى الجيش الاوكراني سوف يتم اتخاذ
القرار قبل 20 من هذا الشهر قبل اجتماع
رامز
الدفاع الدول الشركه الاوكرانيا حذيفه عدد
مباشره من كيف شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الحكومه
الصوماليه تشن حربا على حركه الشباب
المرتبطه بالقاعده
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
صفحه مطويه
من صفحات صعود النازيه
المهاجر الالماني الذي اسس حركه الفاشيه
عنصريه
تمكن من حشد الامصار
وجمع الاموال
واصبح واجهه للنازيه في امريكا
الجمعه الواحده بعد منتصف الليل على
الشاشه العربيه
بهذا الشكل الدمار هائل جدا هذه كانت
مدينه حرب في شوارع موجه تتفقدها تتفقد
الطرقات وتجد صدفه في احدى الطرقات هذا ما
حدث معنا للثوب
سنتقدم معكم بحذر شديد لانه ربما تكون
هنالك ذخيره او قنابل هنالك قنابل نهائيا
يدويه هنالك ذخيره واليات عسكريه مدمره في
كل مكان اينما نظرت تجد اليات عسكريه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي من
جانبي مقبره جماعيه
[موسيقى]
عذاب وقت ما تقدر تاخذ نفس عميق
اوتريفن يزيل احتقان الانف ست مرات اسرع
من الحبوب ويساعدك على التنفس بشكل افضل
لغايه 12 ساعه خذ نفس عميق
مرحبا بكم من جديد السلطات الصوماليه ضاقت
ذرعا من حركه الشباب المرتبطه بالقاعده
والتي تشلها هجمات الارهابيه على البلاد
منذ سنوات مقاديشو اطلقت عمليه عسكريه هي
الاكبر منذ ظهور الحركه وذلك من اجل
القضايا عليها العمليه ستستهلك اساسا
عناصر الحركه سيما المقاتلين منهم هي اذا
حرب شامله تشنها السلطات الصوماليه وعلى
هذه الحركه المنتشره في الكثير من مناطق
البلاد ويعدوا اقليم جوبا الوسطى الوحيد
الذي تسيطر عليه الحركه بالكامل فهو اكثر
اقليم يضم غابات تتحسن فيها قيادات الحركه
وياتي اقليم وجوب السفلي في جوبلاند همم
في المرتبه الثانيه من حيث تشعر مسلح
الحركه هيا تسيطر على نحو 60 بالمائه منه
فيما يحتل اقليم ايران بولايه هيرشبيليا
المرتبه الثالثه
شباب تشن عدد من الهجمات الارهابيه ضد
الحكومه الصوماليه بهدف فرض سيطرتها على
البلاد وتواجه الحركه تهديدات عده ابرزها
التغير المناخي حيث دفع زحف الرمال
والجفاف الاف من السكان للتمرد على حركه
الشباب في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها كما
ان العديد من القبائل رفضوا الدفعه
الضرائب المطلوبه من الحركه هناك بسبب
الجفاف الذي ادى الى تراجع المحاصيل بشكل
كبير كما ان بعض القبائل بادرت الى توفير
الدعم اللوجستيه للجيش الصومالي في حملته
ضد الحركه خاصه من ناحيه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
حركه الشباب الصوماليه
تاسست سنه 2004 كانت الذراع العسكري
لاتحاد المحاكم الاسلاميه
اعلانات الحركه سنه 2009 لتنظيم القاعده
بشكل رسمي
تضم بين صفوفها ما بين
9000 مقاتل بحسب صحيفه الفرنسيه
من بين المقاتلين اجانب اغلبهم من دول
عربيه اضافه الى باكستان
تبول الحركه نشاطتها من خلال القرصنه قبله
سواحل الصومال
اضافه الى الضرائب التي تفرضها في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان دعم القوات المسلحه لكل
خطوه تقود الى الانتقال الديمقراطي
البرهان مجددا ترحيبه بالاتفاق الايطالي
ين
ومسلحه سودانيه حق السودان هي صمام امان
هذا السودان عشان كذا بنقول نحن والله
[موسيقى]
نحن متوقع انه ما تم توقيعه من اتفاق
ايطالي يخرج هذه البلاد
عشان نبني هذا البلد اهلنا سنين طويله
وبلدنا معنا سنين طويله ما عندنا اي طريقه
غير اننا نلبيني اذا الشعب السوداني
[موسيقى]
نيبال ذلك البلد الفقير الواقع في منطقه
الهملايا يهتز على وقعه حادثه تحطم طائره
جديده الامر يتعلق بطائره تابع الي تابعه
لشركه والتي تحطمت بالقرب من مدينه بخارى
في وسط البلد حديث التحطم هذا ادى الى
وفاه كل الركاب وطقم الطائره البالغ عددهم
72 ومن بينهم 15 اجنبيا واربعه من افراد
الطاقه ورضيعين
[موسيقى]
الطائرات متابعه لشركه
في رحلتين من العاصمه كاتماندو الى مدينه
بخارى والتي تقع على بعد 200 كيلو متر غرب
العاصمه اما نوع طائره فهو اي تي ار 72
وهي طائره النتيجه
الايطاليه ويصل عدد مقاعدها الى 78 وتعمل
بمحركين اثنين كما يتعلق طاقها من طيارين
اثنين هذا وتعرضت هذه الطائره
لاثني عشر حادثا لمده منذ بدايه استخدامها
علما ان العديد من الخطوط حول العالم
تستخدمها في الرحلات القصيره
حوادث الطيران ليست نادره في نيبال التي
توجد فيها ثمانيه جبال من بني اعلى اربع
10 قمه في العالم ومن بينها قمه افرست
يضاف الى ذلك تقلب حاله الطقس بشكل مستمر
ما يزيد من الخطوره على الملاحه الجويه
كما ان البلاد تضم ما يصنف اخطر مطار في
العالم وهو مطار مدينه لوكلا
[موسيقى]
معنى من القاهره الكابتن الطيار وخبير
السلام الجويه علي شكري كابتن علي اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه يقال انه
مطارات النبال يعني تشكل تحدي همم
لكابتن الطائره مهما كان متمارسا بسبب
الجبال يعني هي تقع في منطقه الهملايا هل
تعتقد ان هذا يمكن ان يكون سببا من اسباب
سقوط هذه الطائره النيباليه اليوم
اهلا بحضرتك
بالطبع التدريس الجويه الواعره التي تتمتع
بها منطقه الهيمالايا ودوله نيبال بالطبع
تشكل تحديا واضحا لشركات الطيران والطيرين
على وجه
الخصوصا ان مطارات
دوله نيبال كلها تقع في منطقه واعره جدا
مما يصعب من حالات الملاحه الجويه على
الطيارين كذلك فان اا ال- اا خطوط الطيران
ومعظم منظمات الطيران حول العالم تضع
شروطا قاسيا من اجل الطيارين للهبوط او
الاقلاع من هذه المباراه بل تستوجب كثير
من شركات الطيران حول العالم
هل همم هبطت مره في احد همم مطارات النبال
او حلقته في اجوائها سابقا
يجرى الينا كثير من التدريبات على الجهاز
محاكي اغاني التشبيه على هذه المطارات
لبيان مدى صعوبتها لكن فعليا لما لم اهبط
شخصيا في هذه المباراه
ولكن منظمات الطيران وسلطات الطيران
حوالين العالم تضع شروط قاسيه من اجل
الهبوط في هذه المطارات بل تستوجب ايضا او
وجود تدريبات خاصه على الجهاز المحاكي
لطيران او الجهاز السيميليتر او مشابه
الطيران قبل هبوط الى هذه طيب ما هو اهم
التحدي بالنسبه للتيار الجبال
هناك تحديان تحديان
يصنعان فرق كبير في اثناء الهبوط والاطلاع
في هذه المطارات التحدي الاول هي المنطقه
الجبليه التي تستوجب الهبوط في مسارات غير
منتظمه كذلك وضعيه المطار لا يكون في
الاقتراب بشكل مباشر ولكن يجب الالتفاف
حول المطار كذلك التحدي الثاني هو الاجواء
الغير مستقره حيث تختلط الطيارات الساخنه
البارده مما تشكل همم وسيله او او او
بيئه غير مستقره لحالات الطيران ولكن لا
نجد اليوم في هذه في هذه الحادثه ان ان
الاجواء
متداول صح يعني لا يوجد هناك غيوم تؤثر
على الرؤيه طيب كذلك مساله الصيانه
والتدريب كذلك همم بالنسبه للفرق الخاصه
بشركات الطيران هذه الايه حتى انه يمكن
كذلك لعب دور في هذه الحادثه
نحن نجد ان دوله نيبال لا تتمتع بالسجل
نظيف من حوادث الطيران بل على عكس شركه
الطيران ياتي
وسلطه
كل عامان بحادث على على الاقل ولكن هذا
الحادث يعد الاكثر الاما منذ ثلاثه عقود
ولكن هناك هذه الشركه حوادث في العام 2012
و2014
و16 و2018 و20 و21 همم مما جعل الاتحاد
الاوروبي يحظر على جميع الشركات الطيران
النيباليه دخول اجوائها
لا اجد سجل النظيفا ل- ل- لنيبال ولكن لا
يعني هذا ان ان هذا الامر هو الذي تسبب في
الحادث ولكن ما يظهر من من لقطات التي تم
تداولها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بان
حاله الطائره لم تكون في الوضع الصحيح
قبيله الاقتراب والهبوط من المطار حيث
ظهرت همم
اجنحه الطائره تميل الى اليمين والى
اليسار وكانت في وضع غير مستقر همم مما
يرجح فرضيه ان يكون همم حصل انهيار او
ستول للطائره قبل قبل هبوطها ولكن ايضا لا
لا تظهر اللقطات الفيديو حاله صحوه الجو
حيث ان الاضطرابات او المطبات الهويه لا
تظهر بالرؤيه العين المجرده ولكن همم
اليوم وفقا لرصدات التي تم رصدها من من
محطه الرصد الخاصه بالاجواء لا تظهر ان
الع- ان العوامل الجويه قد تسببت في اي
عامل من عوامل سقوط الطائره شكرا جزيلا لك
همم الكابتن الطيار وخبير السلاما الجويه
علي شكري كنت معنا من القاهره
حوادث الطيران بشعه تحدث في نقال كل عامين
تقريبا تنتهي بكوارث واعداد ضحايا كبيره
تضاف لها حادثه اليوم التي اسفرت عن مقتل
72 شخصا
الكارثه التي اسفرت عن مقتل العشرات بعد
تحطم طائره ركاب في نيبال ليست الاولى من
نوعها
على مدى اعوام كثيره حوادث تحطم الطائرات
في نيبال ووقعت اثنتان واربعون حديثه منذ
عام
1946 في العام 1992 176 راكبا على متن
طائره باكستانيه فقدوا حياتهم في العام
2012 تحطم طائره متجهه من بخار الى جونسون
اسفل عن مقتل 15 شخصا في العام 2014
في العام 2016 تحطم طائره توين اوتر ومقتل
جميع ركبها وعددهم 23
في العام 2018 مقتل 49 شخصا بعد تقدم
طائره ميغاليه امريكيه
[موسيقى]
دفع البيت الابيض عن ابتهامات وجهت للرئيس
بايرن بحيازه وثائق السريه والتستر عليها
بعد اكتشافه جديده قائلا ان محاميه الرئيس
متعاونون مع وزاره العدل ويقومون بتسليم
كل الوثائق حاله اكتشافها لمكتب المحفوظات
الوطنيه لكن الرئيس يتعرض لضغوط كبيره
واتهامات بعدم الشفافيه والبعض يرى انه قد
يجرمون قانون ناديا البلبيسي
يوم ان هادئ في البيت الابيض لكنه ينظر
بعاصفه سياسيه فمشاكل الرئيس بيدن
القانونيه تتراكم بعد الكشف عن وثائق سريه
جديده في بيته ليصل مجموعه الوثائق الى 20
وثيقه بعض المحامين المحافظين يرون بان
بيض في خطر اكبر من الرئيس ترامب الذي
احتفظ بحوالي 300 وثيقه في منتجعه في
مارالرجو ورفض التعاون مع المحققين
والمحامين والتهمه بعرقله
والسبب ان ترامب انه نزع السريه عن تلك
الوثائق امر يخوله الدستور حسب بعض
المحامين المحافظين لكن هناك انقسام في
وجهه النظر القانونيه التي تقول بان هذه
الصلاحيه هي من صلاحيات الكونجرس وليس
الرئيس ومهما كابرا او ثوره حجم الخطر
فهناك موسى الى ق وشيكا في مجلس النواب
وهذا قد يؤثر على فرص الرئيس في الترشح
لولايه
منظمه انقذ الاطفال تستانف عملها في
افغانستان بعد تاكيد ذات من طالبان بان
موظفاتها سيعملنا دون عوائق
مرحبا بكم من جديد
الاطفال انها ستسانك عملها في افغانستان
فذلك بعد وعود من طالبان بعدم التعرض
لموظفاتها وقالت المنظمه في بيان انها
تلقى التاكيدات من طالبان بان موظفاتها
يمكنهن العمل العمل دون عوائق مشيره الى
ان المجالات التي
تستانف همم سيستانف العمل فيها تشمل
مجالات الصحه والتغذيه والخدمات التعليميه
يعني
[موسيقى]
خبر وين صار للمتداولين في العملات
المشفره انت عايشه حقيقيه سجلت العملات
المشفره اليوم لاول مره منذ اكثر من شهرين
استقر سعر بتكون فوق مستوى 20,000$
وارتفعت الحصه والسوقيه لاكبر عمله مشفره
بحوالي ب 41
بلغت القيمه السوقيه للعملات المشفره بشكل
الاجمالي حوالي 976 مليار دولار مقتربتا
من اختراق حاجز التريليون دولار هذه
الزيادات في قيمه البيتك وان رفعت مستوى
التداول على العملات المشفره بنسبه 80%
خلال 24
فما هي اسباب هذا الارتفاع يقولوا موقع
كريبتو بوليتر المختص في العملات المشفره
ان هذا الارتفاع راجع بالاساس الى الجهود
التي بذلتها وزاره العدل الامريكيه والتي
ساهمت في القبض على سام بانك بانك برايد
مالك شركه اف تي اكس للعملات المشفره
المتهم بالاحتيال كما ان اعلان الجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب الامريكي عن احداثي لجنه
الفرعيه خاصه للعملات المشفره اعاد الثقه
مجددا للمستثمرين
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الشرطه البريطانيه اعتقال رجل في
الستينيات من عمره على خلفيه ادخال طرد
يورانيوم عبر مطار هيثرو واوضحت الشرطه ان
عمليه الاعتقال جرت في مدينه
شمال غرب انجلترا وكانت الشرطه البريطانيه
قد فتحت حقيقا في اعقابه وصول طرد يحتوي
على اليورانيوم ضبط في مطاره بلندن في
اواخر ديسمبر الموت
[موسيقى]
هل تعود المياه الى مجاريها بين الامير
هاري وافرادي عائلته سؤال بدا يترددوا بعد
الهدوء النسبي الذي حل عقب الضجه التي
اثارها كتاب مذكره الامير هاري صحيفه صندل
في تقرير لها انه من المحتمل حصوله مصالحه
بين الامير هاري والعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
شهر مايو المقبل
الصحيفه استمرت في خبرها الى معلومات
منقوله عن مصدر مقرب من الملك وعلى صله
ايضا بالامير هاري وزوجته ميغان ماركت
واضافت صحيفه ان اجتماعا سيعقد بين هاري
وبعض افراد عائلته في الاشهر المقبله
هذه الاخبار المشاهدين اذا عن العائله
الملكيه التي الى ختام اخبار الساعه لهذه
الليله شكرا لكم على المشاهده المزيد
دائما يبقى على العربيه على مواقع التواصل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]